a familiar staff a Wizard's past
mistakes and a Minotaur in the Big Apple
these are the little things you may have
missed in the new trailer for Shazam
Fury of the Gods we know that shazam's
back to save the day in Fury of the Gods
but who exactly is the big band of the
sequel just going by the cast list it's
easy to assume that Helen mirren's
hespera is the film's main villain still
looking at the trailer hespera's role
kind of seems closer to a DCU equivalent
to the mcu's Odin a powerful figure
who's done a bunch of awful stuff in the
past but generally takes a more advisory
role to their younger Protege by the
time the movie has started you are very
menacing Lucy lose Calypso on the other
hand is another thing entirely she's the
one who makes the best ominous poses and
demolishes sports stadiums with her
monstrous green thumb and that's not
even to mention the fact that she's the
one with the cool dark costume oh and
she's writing an actual Dragon we don't
know yet whether Calypso is going to be
the secret power behind the throne or
just a very imposing Lackey to mirin's
hespera but either way it's great to see
Lucy Liu back on the big screen in a big
way one of the most eye-catching visual
elements of the show Shazam Fury of the
Gods trailers comes in the form of a
magical staff brimming with blue energy
at different points in the trailer
viewers can see both the villains and
the hero all using the staff during
various big blowout battles however it
seems that none of these characters are
actually the true owner of the weapon by
all accounts the staff actually belongs
to the wizard Shazam himself viewers of
the original Shazam may recall that the
wizard uses what is presumably the exact
same staff to Grant Billy his powers and
speaking of Billy's Powers it's not
looking too good for the big red cheese
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
based on the newest trailer it seems
like those fearsome daughters have the
perfect weapon to do so and one moment
in the trailer Mary Marvel is forcibly
transformed back into her mortal form by
the staff losing the one thing that
gives her a fighting chance against the
bad guys while the idea of superheroes
losing their powers isn't necessarily a
novel it'll be interesting to see how
the Shazam family takes on this
adversity both trailers show that
everyone is having a great time with
their new abilities so losing the powers
they've come to rely on might be a big
blow to the Marvel family but it's not
all doom and gloom for Shazam fans most
excitingly it seems like the wizard may
have a far more prominent role than he
had in the first film while he primarily
served as a mentor figure and the cause
of Billy's Powers the new trailer makes
it seem like the daughters of Atlas have
a particular ax to grind against the
kindly wizard early in the trailer
hespera is seen cursing Batson and his
friends from one side of a prison door
children stole the power of the Gods
from our father's call while we don't
see who she's talking to there's a high
chance that it's the wizard who is later
seen blowing gold dust out of a window
while seemingly trapped in a cell are
his past sins coming back to haunt him
will he have enough power to help his
Champion win the day maybe not
especially given that his trusty staff
is being passed around like a mystical
Hot Potato we also know from a previous
teaser that there will be some new
mythical creatures introduced to Billy
Batson's World in Fury of the Gods a
herd of black unicorns and a craggy
looking dragon that breeds blue fire
were the two types of beasties on
display in our first look at the
upcoming movie but the film's second
trailer adds more creatures to the mix
there appears to be a chimera tearing
apart New York City during one of the
teasers most heart-stopping moments also
briefly visible is a black minotaur-like
figure wreaking havoc in the big city
well the dragons appear to be under the
full control of calypso and hespera and
the unicorns seem to have been tamed by
Billy and his siblings it's anybody's
guess how the other Mythic creatures get
involved in the action still it
definitely appears that Shazam Fury of
the Gods is going to have fun with the
mythological aspect of Billy's root when
the movie takes off on March 17th
[Music]